se a efe una función derivable para toda
x si efe evaluada en menos 2 es igual a
3 y la derivada de x es siempre menor o
igual que 7 es decir esto es para toda x
cuál es el mayor valor posible para f en
evaluada en 10 muy bien entonces vamos a
vamos a visualizar esto primero te
invito a que hagas una pausa pienses de
este problema tú mismo
y realmente trates de responder cuál es
el mayor valor para f de 10 muy bien
entonces piénsalo y ahorita lo
trabajamos juntos
entonces suponiendo que ya lo pensaste
ya lo intentaste vamos a comparar
nuestras formas de resolver el problema
y primero voy a visualizarlo poniendo
una gráfica
digamos que este no fue un bonito eje va
de nuevo
digamos que ahí tienen ustedes el eje y
tienen el eje que corresponde a donde
voy a graficar la función y voy a pintar
ahora el eje x
ahí tienen
y tienen más o menos el eje x muy bien
que se vea bien que es el eje perdón el
eje x entonces nos dice que menos 2 aquí
digamos aquí anda menos 2 por supuesto
no van a hacer escalas escalas correctas
y no va a estar es solo para para más o
menos identificar el problema en menos
dos vale tres ok entonces aquí está el
valor de tres y aquí está nuestro primer
punto muy bien nos preguntan cuánto vale
efe en 10 entonces digamos que aquí que
aquí anda 10 y no sabemos cuánto vale
sin embargo sabemos que en todos lados
la derivada debe ser menor o igual que 7
entonces por ejemplo en un caso extremo
podríamos pensar que es una línea de
pendiente 7 que en todos lados tiene
pendiente 7 entonces piensen en esa
línea digamos como como ahorita como una
restricción y cada vez que nosotros
vayamos avanzando en realidad no podemos
avanzar o no podemos inclinarnos tanto
como para
para sobrepasar esa pendiente entonces
qué es lo que va a ocurrir que
definitivamente como sea esta función va
a ser mucho menor va a ser mucho menor
que si tuviéramos el máximo valor para
esta derivada por ejemplo podría ser así
o quizás mucho menos inclinado quizás
algo así entonces como te darás cuenta
no importa como gráfica es la función si
no quieres que la derivada pase está
pendiente entonces necesariamente vas a
estar abajo de esto muy bien entonces
esto lo podemos ver muy bien usando el
teorema del valor medio por ejemplo cuál
sería el cambio en g entre el cambio en
x si consideramos está pendiente muy
bien entonces esto
esto sería bueno no necesariamente está
pendiente si consideramos cualquiera de
las gráficas tendríamos que el cambio
que sería efe de 10 verdad
- efe evaluada en dos pero f
perdón en menos dos pero f evaluada en
menos dos estrés así que si tomamos f de
menos 2 igual a 3 tenemos eso y si
dividimos entre el cambio en x sería
menos -2 y esto será igual a la derivada
a la derivada en algún punto x pero esto
si nos tomamos el caso extremo sería 7
verdad sería 7 entonces esto simplemente
se convierte en un problema de despejar
y entonces por ejemplo 10 - menos 2
estos son 12 y si pasamos multiplicando
el 12 entonces tendremos efe de 10 menos
3 igual a 12 por 7 que éstos son 2 por 7
son 14 y llevó una 7 por unas 7 y una
son 8 son 84 si sumamos ahora tres de
ambos lados tenemos que f de 10 será
igual a 87 y este será el máximo valor
que puede tomar por este argumento
geométrico que acabamos de ver hace unos
momentos